JENN: Hello.
Just kidding.
My friend at Apple taught me that.
How is everyone doing tonight?
[ Applause ]
It's like 2:00 in the morning.
You did it.
I so, backstage they have like a makeup station
and the sound guy is like, oh, do you need
makeup?
I think I have enough going on here?
Do I look good?
Of course I do.
Anyway.
Along with that and the layout and aggressiveness
of this slide, I think that should set the
tone for the rest of the talk.
So, despite what Lori said in his talk this
morning, I'm not talking about WebAssembly.
I think they misread the schedule.
That's actually Max's talk which is moved
to tomorrow.
So, please check it out.
I'm here today to talk about package managers.
I'm just kidding.
[ Laughter ]
Oh!
And before I go on, I know this counts towards
a ton of my talk.
Where is Keith Kurson?
Is Keith here?
Oh, here.
Happy birthday, Keith.
[ Applause ]
Cool.
Clapping, a round of applause for the organizers,
volunteers, speakers, sponsors.
Awesome.
Thank you so much for having me tonight.
Which was supposed to be a talk I called JavaScript
considered useful.
But then I saw that the conference schedule
had my talk this late.
And so, I switched things up a bit.
So, thank you for sticking around this late
for the first episode and maybe last of my
new hit show "JavaScript After Dark."
Night time is a time to reflect on the past
day.
Like, did we feel productive?
Did we meet our goals of meeting new people?
Saying hi to old friends?
Not drinking too much coffee?
Who here drank too much coffee?
Did we learn some new stuff from the talks
today?
Like how capitalism is bad, right?
Wow.
It's also a time to reflect on those moments
we can't ever take back.
Whose flashbacks keep us up at night.
Important and impactful meaningful moments
like this time a woman asked me in lower Manhattan
three years ago at that red X there where
the Chase bank was.
And I said I didn't know.
But it turns out we were literally in front
of a Chase bank.
I think about it every night.
Tonight, we're going reflect on some just
as insomnia inducing past and present moments
of JS.
The language, the community and me.
Tonight, I am your tall shadowy figure hovering
over you above sleep paralysis.
Now, we're not going to reflect on the birth
of JavaScript 23 years ago.
There's a wealth of content online you can
read about.
How it came to be.
And it wasn't even the most exciting thing
to happen in 1995.
That, of course, goes to Space Hog's debut
album, if you're into British glam rock.
Oasis released what's the story morning glory.
But that's just as uninteresting to me tonight
as the JavaScript origin story.
I bet you didn't think that someone from outside
the world of package managers would be bringing
the hottest takes to the JavaScript conference.
But here we are.
The only year in the past that we are going
to talk about is probably the most impactful
to all of us tonight and that is ten years
ago.
That is 2009.
I know a lot of math.
So, what were JavaScript, the community and
I up to in 2009?
And how we all have collectively grown up
since.
So, let's explore.
In 2009, JavaScript had just about started
getting use to the actually being useful.
Both for normals and nerds.
The iPhone had only been out for about two
years.
So, the idea of JavaScript in everyone's pockets
was real.
But it was still in its infancy.
Not a lot of people knew.
And it had been about four years since AJAX
had come about.
And I think stronger than dirt is a pretty
good bar to reach for scripting languages.
In part with AJAX, web 2.0 was evolving from
user interactions like shit posting comments,
to collaboration and real time shit posting
comments with Google wave.
They reprogrammed the algorithm that most
use today like Glitch.
So, honestly, haters of Google Wave can eat
it.
GitHub and StackOverflow were about a year
old.
And the most popular JavaScript questions
from that year were a reflection of the language's
youth and complexity.
Which nearly matched that of the social construct
of time which to this day we still have issues
with
in JavaScript.
Prototype, jQuery, all a few years old.
It's about the user interface, baby.
I'm sorry, I cringe whenever I hear that.
For the client side, there wasn't much besides
the cringy taglines and logos.
Entirely exciting or dramatic going on.
And to be fair, this is the year before backbone
was released.
So, there was no real framework wars in sight
yet.
It would be another year before Steve Jobs
would release his viral YouTube video/open
letter, thoughts on Flash.
By the way, Flash ends of life next year.
So, rich people and blogging males weren't
quite yet talking about HTML5 as if it were
like an actual brand new language literally
to solve every problem yet.
It was a simpler, softer, more down to Earth
time for the document object model and those
of us fucking around with it.
But that's not to say that 2009 was without
excitement or even conflict and drama.
Shouts out to the TC39 panel a little bit
earlier.
It looked a lot different back then.
Looked a lot different last year.
They were having a tough time coming to a
resolution to a debate that I will summarize
as I do most in the community, grownups fighting
on blogs instead of saying it to their faces.
Blogs, for the unfamiliar, it was how people
put long threads of Tweets into a single page,
by the way.
RIP.
And TC39 for those that missed the panel,
it was great panel.
It's a technical committee to which large
companies pay 70K or more dollars to join.
And what does or doesn't change with JavaScript
the language.
It appears that in 2009 the committee of the
pulling a weekend at Bernie's with the math
icon John Von Neumann.
Fun fact, Neumann invented merge sort, the
second best sorting algorithm next to Jortsort.
I don't know.
Maybe this is what TC39 was fighting about.
Honestly, it was one of the least interesting
things I was reading about in 2009.
But to be fair, there was a lot of competition
in being interesting.
Remember, Google Wave came out that year.
And by the way, it's hard not to see some
irony in the year collaboration was disrupted,
some dudes from large companies had a hard
time collaborating with each other.
Maybe that's the hardest problem in computer
science.
But if you stare directly into the sun, you
may find it interesting that the resolution
of this particular conflict was the committee
renaming ECMAScript 3.1 to ECMAScript fifth
edition.
The version, one point, nine points, is a
huge thing back thing.
It was a few years later that TC39 had another
conflict and moved up the version 2009 points.
Obviously, an homage to the 2009 renaming.
Numerologists should be all over this shit.
Most of the news about JavaScript 2009 was
not about JavaScript, but about browsers who
were all allegedly the best.
Stallman was mad about open source.
And, yeah, some things haven't changed.
Companies tracking us.
So, you know, we knew.
We were warned.
But the most exciting news you would agree
in the JavaScript cannon for developers was
the founding of the modern JavaScript specification
and the release of NodeJS a few months later.
Whoo, yeah.
Whoo.
So, like 2009 was like a growth spurt year.
Our youthful and complex JavaScript was finally
going through puberty.
You know who wasn't going through puberty?
Me.
I was 24 years old in 2009.
And if you go off my Tweets from that year
alone, I was dealing with excruciating wisdom
tooth pain which I couldn't afford to fix
because I was broke as fuck.
So, I took recreational drugs to curb the
pain instead and expressed myself on the Internet
and doing so.
I was in Rob Thomas and deleting the Internet
before that became cool.
And I freaking loved Yahoo!
Pipes.
Shouts out.
What would probably surprise you, I was not
writing much JavaScript.
I was in graduate school working on my master’s
in computer science and my last year's courses
were virtually all mathematics.
And when not writing pages and pages of pure
math, quite beautifully, I must add, I was
programming in R.
Who here knows R?
So, for those of you who are unfamiliar with
R, it's similar to S. Very self explanatory.
[ Laughter ]
I had a lot of odd jobs back then.
But my most fulfilling was teaching non technical
college students how to use Excel at 7 a.m.
I love this review from them who said the
class topics themselves are really boring.
But it's not like she invented Microsoft Office
and forced it upon us.
I did not invent Microsoft Office, but I did
create the curriculum.
So, yeah.
7 a.m.
Fun times.
I have no idea what StackOverflow or GitHub
were.
And those sites are probably not even actively
considering me a part of their target core
demographic.
I was a young white woman studying computer
science, stats and linear algebra in a state
school in New Jersey.
In 2009 that was like the conventional path
to becoming a software engineer if you were
broke and living on your own and the only
person in your family to go to college.
I don't think there were any web developer
bootcamps in 2009.
And most higher education engineering programs
were using Java and C++ and to this day to
teach programming at an applicable level.
JavaScript was copying and pasting from cool
sites and blogs I liked to look at and follow
using Google Reader.
Remember?
I do.
Googlers in here, I remember what you did.
Also, I want to shouts out to my old D and
D crew.
Brian Brennans here.
I forgot to take my D and D handbook and my
glittery dice out of the shop before I took
it.
And the elephant says PHP.
PHP is JavaScript with question marks.
[ Laughter ]
I did a lot of really shitty part time freelance
web design and development.
Yes, design.
With a wide range of low or no paying clients
and most of that development work was written
in PHP.
Which is way prettier than the designs I was
expected to come up with.
So, yeah, my then boyfriend's dad's friend's
real estate company who didn't pay me learned.
Joan Osborne, Grammy nominated singer, performer,
of what is God is one was us hated what I
designed.
And the movie baby geniuses was adapted from.
He was sick as fuck.
He hate what had I designed.
But as my friend said when his kid vomited
on him, tough, but fair.
I didn't Tweet about JavaScript until 2010.
Far from helpful.
I shan't be purchasing this services from
you.
To me, programming community let alone JavaScript
community didn't really exist.
Programming in general didn't exist outside
of the classroom and maybe in a couple of
channels.
And this one mailing list I participated in
about my favorite operating system, open Solaris.
Pour one out for that.
While TC39 was arguing about whatever they
were arguing about in 2009, Oracle was buying
Sun microsystems.
With that was the end of the Open Solaris
project.
I was heartbroken and still pissed at Oracle.
You know what else died in 2009?
GeoCities.
Yeah.
So, this may seem hella dramatic.
But I was basically watching everything important
to me about open source and building the web
being destroyed in a very tiny bubble that
was very far and very different from the bubble
that I am in today which is the JavaScript
community.
The JavaScript community, what many of us
call the communities, what we see here tonight.
Young, we think of JSConf, the family conferences
and EU.
And this conference started in 2009 in response
to or after the inaugural JSConf US earlier
this year.
You may recognize the organizers.
Little baby Jan.
I like that Jan grew his beard over the past
ten years so he can dye it pink just for us
tonight.
In the pink there, I can't believe you spoke
at your own conference.
That's like wearing a Green Day shirt to a
Green Day concert.
It's bad ass.
And notice I'm not making fun of AMP in this
talking.
So, while to me there was no community, it
definitely did exist somewhere.
And allegedly it was rock and roll.
And remember, I love rock and roll.
So, why didn't anyone tell me about this?
I mean, if you look at this image and you
look at the earlier couple of years' images
and that like intro, you'll probably realize
that I wasn't part of the core target demographic
of not only many of the tools that came out
in 2009, but these events.
And that's not meant to be shade.
That's reality.
In 2009 it was very hard to see someone like
me in the audience of an event like this.
Let alone on stage visible and admired by
the tech community.
Also, these conferences were in they're expensive
as hell.
And I don't know about the rest of you all
who at least like went to college.
But the predatory textbook industry ate up
whatever so called disposable income I had.
Plus, I needed to buy weed because my wisdom
teeth were hurting.
Just kidding, I've never done a crime.
But today, 2009 plus ten equals 2019.
I can better support myself and others.
And not only am I actively part of the JavaScript
community.
I'm literally right here on stage at the tenth
JSConf.
Or at least the tenth year that they've had
it.
Soc, congrats to the organizers and everyone
for such a long run.
Let's give everyone a another round of applause.
[ Applause ]
What a wild ride this past ten years have
been.
For one, I don't have wisdom teeth anymore.
So, that's great news.
In less great news, I also don't have Google
reader, Google wave or Yahoo! pipes.
Ten years I was mad at Oracle.
Today the feeling is mutual.
This is a Tweet by an Oracle employee after
this conference announced my speaking.
Please don't find this person and I give him
shit.
He is correct, JSConf EU is better than this.
Using this to represent me.
This conference will be hearing from my lawyers.
And by the way, it needs to be said that me
making fun of Oracle owning the JavaScript
trademark is not punching down.
Because unlike Larry Ellison, I don't own
a fucking island with a volcano on it.
He's going to be just fine.
JavaScript the fame, though.
Maybe it's not time to worry about that.
Capitalism is bad.
So, yea, not only do I write a lot of JavaScript,
I'm an exec at one of the most exciting in
the JavaScript ecosystem.
Yeah, Glitch.com.
Yeah, shouts out.
I get to lead and work with some of the best
engineers, designers and business people in
the world and we're all working together to
make it so that everyone who uses the web
can create the web.
It's been wild to start to see that happen.
And not only is it happening, but people are
building apps on Glitch that I couldn't imagine
would be possible within the confines of the
browser and this beloved portable dynamic
language we use.
Like, I'm not even saying hard to see like
ten years ago.
Like, I couldn't imagine this stuff, or double
stuff, five years ago.
Things like virtual reality and motion detection
in the browser.
We have a cool web VR starter kit and we have
been working with Mozilla on making cool demos.
And like, in the browser.
Like, who'd have thank you?
Machine learning and music, shoutout to really
cool stuff with JS.
And people asking about the questions about
the new metal group Evanescence, the answer
is going under is their best song.
And people on the note extending services
and even content management services like
WordPress with their Gutenberg editor.
So, it's sick.
Game Devs are not only making games on Glitch,
but they're building them in a way so those
that don't typically design and build games
can do so with their own levels.
And that is also super sick.
And speaking of games, that quiz game that
you have been playing is a Glitch app.
But also like under the hood, we have a powerful
as hell collaborative editor written in JavaScript
that runs in the browse their lets everyone
write JavaScript and other languages collaboratively.
And even view server-side JavaScript in the
browser.
So, like the scale of access to writing JavaScript
in 2019 among all the editors is matched only
by the access to learning it this year.
You know?
There are bootcamps now and there's online
learning and they're expanding the options
and opportunities for people to enter the
community and industry.
Even the books about JavaScript today show
not only is the community growing in number
of developers and technologies, but the backgrounds
of those using JavaScript is changing.
I want to give a shoutout to Daniel of Coding
Train, awesome series.
Nick Morgan, writing with JavaScript for kids
book.
And all the like awesome great initiatives
like Black Girls Code.
Giving like people getting people of all ages
and backgrounds into our community so that
we all collectively cannot only build the
web together.
But build like an ethical web that solves
the problems that we all actually have and
solves everyone's problems.
Not just a core group.
People aren't just asking, you know, anymore
how to use JavaScript to redirect a page or
figure out the name of the month.
They're asking JavaScript they're asking how
to JavaScript to tell a story with data around
gun violence and political activism
And we're learning and teaching literature
and art using the language.
So, shouts out to re Publica, color of change,
awesome organization.
My large son, Angus Cole for writing with
JavaScript.
And the institute, my own project.
It's like the side project or indefinite hiatus
and fronted.
And not only does JavaScript the language
look different, the people writing and talking
about JavaScript do too.
Shouts out to all of my fellow speakers that
the event.
Round of applause for them.
And the MCs.
[ Applause ]
And don't you dare let anyone tell you that
the diversity and who is writing all this
code and the brilliance of what is being made
with it are a coincidence.
It's not.
And we have a lot more work to do to make
it actually diverse and inclusive and we can
only imagine how awesome and how brilliant
the things coming out of this language will
be when we are at the point and beyond that
we could say that.
Anyway, 2009 was a wild year.
But 2019 is fucking lit.
Which makes it incredibly hard to imagine
what could be in store for us in 2029?
But I flew all the way out here so let's give
it a go.
These are my hopes and dreams for 2029.
The first: You might have noticed my avatar
on the website.
I gave them one that had my face and the skeleton
zoomed in.
I was told that the reason my conference head
shot is zoomed in on the skeleton is because
of AI.
Which means we're all going to die.
But honestly, in 2029, a significant amount
if not majority of code will be written by
machines.
That shouldn't be surprising with all the
talk about artificial intelligence in this
industry.
This has been planned for decades.
If you read early text that's on artificial
intelligence, like the people who created
that idea did it so like machines would write
our code for us.
Like, work for ourselves.
Like, machines can do it.
And we've already boilerplated and automated
a lot via command line interfaces.
Which is rad.
But we're going to need some nice slick graphical
user interfaces to bring that development
to the masses.
Much like some of our favorite operating systems
did for computing in general.
So, that's a cycle we're entering into now.
And because we need GUIs, there's a lot of
abstraction and design challenges that come
with it.
So, that means that those specializations
we saw starting to disappear over the past
ten years like content and style, separate
concerns from interaction, I think that those
things are going to become more discrete again.
And with that, like the role of frontend and
backend will become rarely used unironically
as much as the phrase close to the middle
is.
I think we're gonna see a lot more specialization
in our community.
And front and back will be replaced with UI,
ML, AI, IoT. hope they come up with another
phrase than IoT.
I don't like that.
Too many letters.
VR.
I would say hobbyists or maker, but I think
that's also kind of like the maker movement
is still quite misogynist because women have
been doing crafts and yarn and that shit for
years.
Hopefully there's a better word that doesn't
bring the patriarchal theme in.
Way specialized and there are going to be
generalists to mentor, coach and educate new
and seasoned specialists.
So, I think like the thing that we need to
worry about, and I'm seeing it already in
our community, is the gap in value and pay
of educators in the industry.
Yeah.
[ Applause ] shouts out to my teachers.
And not like the engineers who teach on the
side because it's extra money and they don't
really care about the people that they're
teaching.
No.
Anyway.
I can't go on these tangents.
I'm going to get people mad.
That gap, by the way, I think should be can
be filled with all the money Microsoft is
spending on trying to figure out who horse
JS is.
Just saying.
Ryan Dahl will be doing a mistakes I made
making Dino tour.
Ryan, if you watch this video, you're a treasure.
Please don't hate me.
But I'm right.
Microsoft is going to shut down GitHub and
VS code in their master plan to get us back
to using Microsoft Word to build HTML pages
like nature intended.
And because Word doesn't allow JavaScript,
all y'all who are like JavaScript is considered
harmful folks will finally be happy.
But then you'll realize your brand has become
obsolete.
So, sorry about that.
Make E CMA will update their website design.
Also, you see all the trademarks down there?
That's an update.
If any of y'all are here still.
I want to propose some hot new trendy dark
modes.
Or an old classic, hot dog stand.
Even better, maybe in 2029 we'll have designed
and implemented a more diverse and inclusive
way to evolve the language than leaving it
up to only large English speaking corporations
who can afford not only a seat at the table,
but the flight and hotel to wherever that
table keeps moving around to.
Now, given the number of people in this room
and my background in statistics and getting
yelled at on the Internet.
I will say it's highly probable that some
of you are thinking, Jenn, why are you complaining
about diversity when you said this event is
more diverse than it was ten years ago?
And yes, Uncle Bob, from my extreme white
woman perspective, we're doing a bit better
this decade when it comes to D&I.
But I predict and hope that by continuing
and evolving this work, in ten years the need
for diversity scholarships will have dwindled
or have been made obsolete by the fact that
companies will value all of their employees
enough to sponsor their being a part of these
events.
Or at the very least, people will not complain
on Twitter about people of color having their
own space at these events.
[ Applause ]
Just a reminder.
We are living in a misogynist and white supremacist
society.
And that plays into a lot of the stuff happening
over the next ten years in AI.
I don't want to slip that under the rug.
These are hopes and dreams and I'm hoping
that more people are involved, and more diverse
people are involved so we can undo the damage
and prevent that.
That's an aside off script.
I can talk for hours about that.
But I think another thing is that all of us
community organizers will have hopefully evolved
the conference experience so that yeah!
Fuck yeah!
Are they playing Foosball?
Are they getting excited about Foosball?
Shaking my head.
Anyway, yeah!
I think that we will make it so that all people
can still know the community exists and feel
like they're a part of it even if they're
like I was in 2009.
Which was too broke to travel and/or too lost
to know what I was supposed to be looking
for.
And I predict that a lot of people writing
code in ten years, if not the majority of
people writing code in ten years, will not
be developers but trade.
So, we need to welcome them to this experience
as well.
As well as TC39 whatever hopefully non corporate
professional group is running the show.
And it's been said that this will be the last
JSConf EU which in the wake of my Microsoft
Word prediction, I'm not surprised.
Much like every conference, though I think
they'll skip a year or two and keep going
for years to come.
I'm thinking this might be my last JavaScript
talk.
I said that a few years ago and came back.
Jay Z said he wasn't making music anymore
and then he came back.
I don't know.
I just think that something like this is too
magical and beautiful.
And to give up this ability to bring different
people together to learn and grow with each
other.
It won't run quite the same, this conference,
though, and it shouldn't, because what the
language and community look like is rapidly
changing.
So, you know, those of you here running companies
and popular projects in the ecosystem, I want
you to take note of that dynamic changing.
I think it's becoming hella evident today
and not that not only are more companies in
our ecosystem going to have to live by the
value that all people matter more than the
tech we're building.
But the survival of their business will depend
on their being accountable and honest to those
values.
You know?
They're staffed by and used by the community.
And so, those of us running companies in that
space need to like walk the walk sprint, even
more than talking the talk.
Yeah.
I mean, as an aside, I was just thinking a
lot about CJ's talk.
It's been really hard to witness what's been
going on at npm.
Because like at Glitch we talk about like
we're trying to get everyone to be able to
build the we can, and our product is very
focused on people.
And it just sucks when like someone in the
ecosystem just like fucks up something and
it sets the rest of us who are trying to do
good work back.
And that's fine.
We were ready to do the work.
We're here for the fight.
Like, we're gonna do it.
And we're gonna win.
We're counting on it.
But I'm just hoping that you all still you
all question companies and ask questions and
keep us honest and hold us accountable.
Because some of us like want to do you right.
We're trying.
We're trying really hard.
And while tech is already political, in 2029
I predict there will be significantly fewer
cowards pretending it's not.
[ Applause ]
As for me, I don't know where I see myself
in ten minutes, let alone ten years.
Besides, of course, hotter and smarter.
Let's be honest.
Thank you.
Where I see myself in the future has always
been my hardest problem in computer science.
Like, I know where I'm at now and that's like
living a life and in a world that I never
could have imagined ten years ago.
Let alone two years ago.
Three months before I joined Glitch, I was
exploring how to quit tech because I fell
really ill and I just couldn't manage going
to work every day miserable and also physically
being miserable.
One of those had to give, that was tech.
And fortunately, an opportunity came around
and I ended up at Glitch.
And I felt great.
But I could never see that path happening
and it's very scary when you enter a space.
Even someone in the game as long as me and
not knowing what's ahead of you.
Not having any visibility.
It took a lot of hitting road blocks, earning
degrees and dodging obstacles, getting yelled
at on the Internet on the regular and a fuck
ton of work to get where I am today.
It was not a direct path, becoming a woman
in leadership.
And I'm not confident that such a path is
available for anyone else.
Let myself to continue.
You know?
Something might happen and in three months
or six months I might be like you know what?
Something's got to give.
I got to go back to teaching Excel at 6 a.m.
or 7 a.m.
Whatever the fuck it was.
I'm not a morning person anymore.
I don't want that to happen.
But I predict or at least hope that with like
the work we're all doing, like all of us in
this room and helping everyone on the web
create the web that our community in 2029
will be more visible and accessible.
As well as the definition of success for individuals.
More and different people will not only get
a say in how our language evolves, but they'll
get time on stage.
The safety that comes with being valued and
fairly paid.
I think that or hope that they'll be able
to see themselves continuing on that path
and reaching their ideal destination.
That they're not just sort of walking blindly
like I feel I am myself today.
And I think with that, they'll hopefully be
a little more confident in coaching other
generations and types of coders to reach their
ideal destinations as well.
And I think a lot of prominent visible marginalized
people in this industry have many stories
like this to tell.
But, you know, one day a woman came up to
me and was like, I really look up to you.
I follow you on Twitter.
I'm like, sorry.
And she's like, I want to, like, be you in
two years.
And I'm like, girl, I couldn't be me in two
years.
And I can't tell you how to be me in ten years.
That's what I'm hoping will change.
I hope that path will include building like
awesome apps that solve everyone's problems.
I hope it includes leading a team of the Greatest
engineers in the world and, you know, even
flying thousands of miles to shit post Larry
Ellison.
A volcano on the island.
Look it up.
If I play my cards right, and y'all let me
play them, I think that I'll be doing all
of those things still.
Maybe not flying miles to shit post Larry
Ellison.
That's like a one and done thing.
I think that maybe I'll be helping some Glitch
employee work on their dot doc XEU talk where
they showcase all the amazing apps that our
rad community made that year.
And we asked the community about 2029, it
was facilitating farming, supplying energy,
quantum computing, challenging the social
construct time.
The news in a social media dystopia.
And maybe even just simply making websites.
I know that my hair will probably be all gray
which will look sick as hell.
I hope any wisdom teeth don't grow back.
I don't know, climate change.
Like you never know what's gonna happen.
Anti vaxxers.
But I'm pretty confident that every night
I'll be lying wide awake, just like for years,
reflecting on the moment where I told the
woman in front of the bank that I did not
know where the Chase bank was.
Maybe the sun will burn out.
Thank you.
Thank you for sticking around for JavaScript
after dark.
I'm Jenn, smash those links, please subscribe.
And I'll see you on Glitch.com.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]